[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to GameSpot
c3 2018 coverage it is finally time we
were about to play Smash Bros ultimate
I'm Mike McCarty here with Lucy James
hello and we are also here from the
treehouse daniel joins us to talk about
smash bros we got some of the fine folks
from Nintendo treehouse behind us we're
gonna be playing it live while not
awesome for that we're gonna be talking
over a live demo so you saw it here
first
not Nintendo Direct no I'm just kidding
anyway take it hope it's a first time on
GameSpot yes yes so every single
character that's ever been in the smash
game is gonna be an ultimate over 60
different characters yeah be announced
it'll be all the characters that have
ever been in the franchise up to now and
new ones as well as you've seen the
inkling Ridley and even Daisy's now
making an appearance in the game yeah I
saw the Daisy Ridley memes if that was
hinting it's something I haven't seen
the Daisy Ridley means yet but anyway
alright but also as well as a lot of
like a slew of changes to every
character you were saying Ganondorf is
the Ocarina Ganon to ocarina time she
has a sword now as well and then you've
got there's that champion Link act and
links in there as well
well bombs for his new boss and that
made it even if you have 0% damage the
excess of projectile as though he was
mirroring having full health and that
same one everybody started playing - oh
yeah oh here we go the great plateau
tower you could see it over there as
well yeah and they got a ganondorf the
Inklings in there as well a new
character ice climbers are back again
and then Popo
I see I'm pretty excited to see snake I
don't know if we'll see it on the stage
people are freaking out about snake
hates is back hairs back Isis we're all
a huge news this morning yeah just so
great seeing so many different
characters come back into the fold that
haven't seen a lot I'm a huge ice
climbers fan so I'm stoked to see ice
climbers back for sure
mechanically you were telling us before
that and they were showing the direct
you can air directional dodge in the air
now you know air dodge directionally not
just yet done just air dodge in the face
there's things like that all these
little subtle changes they've added to
the gameplay mechanics just to make it
feel more different
it feels faster it kind of it's better
to be more aggressive in the game a
little more aggression yeah that'd be
that to make those quicker smashes even
subtle things like
assist trophies yeah given this history
if you actually so much disco as you can
kom can get and get Kalos for yourself
as well
that's kind of changed up that as well
we mentioned before was a fake Smash
Ball yeah I think Smash Ball announced
you have to worry about really ash ball
fake Smash Ball
yeah and we're also looking at a new
stage right here yeah the great the
great plateau tower for all your breath
of the wild fan but not any other ones
that you could talk more about we have
more more eight hours available to demo
as well they show some others in the in
the direct as well but we're playable
here we've got one and more eight hours
okay awesome and then you've got a bunch
of Fire Emblem characters coming back I
mean literally every character that's
ever been in Smash oh geez every
character there's a lot in that roster I
keep thinking about more and more
secretly a test to see how well you know
how I remember even one of them they've
been trying to that for a while and it's
just so many every character you get a
chance to explore and talk to and see
how they play everyone's got their
favorites so I just pens what you want
to figure out and play with and see how
that plays differently like I'm a big
I'm a big Samus fan yeah the fact that
Samus now can charge her or her charge
beam in the air yeah charge in the air
which doesn't change up as well so I
think our friend Jake Decker he's
upstairs editing right now but he's a
big Samus minute he'll probably happy to
hear that
and now Ridley is the first non samus
metroid character to appear yes a second
character in there for sure what side 0
shoot there's all right beside zero suit
samus God's and zero Gabby but there's
also I didn't realize how big the
community that what has been like making
memes about really being a smash have
been and now he's here and there's such
a dark trailer it looked like Mega Man
got like yeah a little bit dark me hey
can I get a nice it's nice to have fun
with a different series and how it
crosses over all those different ways as
well and then seeing in a Gibeon clean
character dimension or the Inklings a
whole new character different mechanic
we actually have to worry about
recharging recharging it's it's gauge of
ink okay actually of a splatter shot jr.
if you shoot someone the more you cover
them in ink when you hit them they take
more damage okay norm overall more
damage you can start doing different
combos on that as well there's a splat
roll you can actually splat roll someone
and knocks them into the ground you can
pop up and then to kind of use the ink
paintbrush and whack them back okay you
start people I just wanted seeing how
people are already trying to create new
combos with what how the characters
playing everything as well you were
saying with one on one combat you'll
build up percentage faster yeah you take
more damage faster in one-on-one I think
the example they show in the direct to
like seeing four it was playing four
player smash in fifth character I hit
new take like say twenty three percent
damage they showed the other one up to
twenty eight kind of keep the game speed
moving a little bit
even a ties into the final smashes the
final smashes they've tried to go a bit
more making them happen quicker like
there's no more land master and with box
now it's more of a his squad flies into
some kind of cool and stay cool we've
got another match going on right now yes
here's great showers and Ridley yeah and
these in there really Marth curtly Marth
Pikachu Kirby my boy which okay your
crib and your crew back yeah
Lucy's relieved to see Kurt jana kirby
and pikachu i saw a lot of people
freaking out about pokemon as well this
one yeah the glob hammer what an
asteroid in the background but this map
is is this a new map is it's a new map
there's a brand new a new stage which
need to do this one too is that it fit
the the little ramps so actually if you
start running like with the splat roller
it just takes you downward a quick way
oh well so it's it's a different kind of
it's not exactly the same you're used to
with regular platformers but instead
it's kind of this going up and down and
running up and down and it kind of
changes how you play the game a bit so
it seems like it's like a virtual who's
who of the smash roster since inception
but but also it's like it seems like a
Greatest Hits right I'm also curious
like you mentioned like you can air
directional dodge a bunch of character
tweaks new maps a few new characters but
are there any other big each structural
changes we can expect or is this pretty
much like just like a continuation of
what people got the plan it's a brand
new game in his own creation so it's
gonna have its own feel to how it plays
out there so yeah again there's like
over thousands of thousands of changes
being made compared to any of the
previous titles of the characters so and
with all these new characters coming
back into the fold that changes how
everything plays out and I start
tweaking all these characters to become
this huge match up with like differ and
I said different moves
an example is palutena yeah palutena
used to have a block which is kind of
but now it's also a counter so just
being reflecting out reflect or counter
gotcha
they're trying to add things and to make
all these other characters be more
useful in the whole spectrum I can't
even imagine the the balancing that's
had to go on and the QA to make sure
that every all of these you think
thousands of changes what the way
they're supposed to they spend a lot of
time on the dev team just a to spend
forever trying to tweak tweak tweak
tweak to again I'm sure you people play
this demo and we Nate for the final
version character will have changed
again as well as they see like where
they balancing out is the balance really
they're the way mr. Sakurai the
he wants it to end up at all right and
you were saying that the roster is not
even fully announced yet we've said over
60 characters yeah
more to come we'll say think there's 64
right now that we know of if I if my
counting was all right in that graphic
that sounds right and that's and that's
we get in that discussion 200 there's a
release final smash that was awesome
that really actually arrives the
character throws - and misses and then
just love like crazy very very good and
and I'm curious what's it like like
bringing smash to switch I mean like now
like we can it seems like tailor-made to
be the game that like like I obviously
Mario Kart was great to like just pull
the joy Khan's off and play on the small
screen like on a flight or something I
can see myself just squeezing in smash
matches I always actually plan on the
plane with my pro controller like I get
a stand I bring - roller if you're like
what are you doing and they're like they
I look a little weird never know after a
while they're like can i play they want
to do is they're playing with you as
well any kind of things yeah yeah you
can play a tabletop you can play a
handheld you be able to play on the TV
you have all those options that whole
idea of taking the switch anywhere
putting together
anybody you want that kind of fun is
always right there built-in right you
were talking about like it's gonna feel
different it's very much its own game
you know you got melee which is much
faster paced still played in the pro
level today brawl slowed down a bit I
think we you found a balance between the
two would you say that ultimate is more
like one of those three than the others
or thing everyone's gonna feel different
about it maybe start comparing people
are gonna make natural comparisons I'm
sure but to me I just kind of view each
smash game jump in have fun see word
feels and Ivan played I haven't played a
little while so it's kind of fun jumping
back in and getting where it goes I know
there's some of my friends who are super
Pro competitors and they play all the
time
there's some friends who are gonna be
like oh they're great they'll jump back
in casually and that's the fun of the
game too is that it's 2 to 8 1 to 8
players and what you want and that's
where items come into play as well some
people like items some people don't like
items I'm I go both ways depending on
who's playing
but it's so it's just fun for everybody
and it's also it's I think it's worth
looking at the switch in terms of its
sales is astronomical on its own but
also compared to the Wii U I feel like
there's a lot of people who might have
played brawl missed out on Smash Bros
you and now we're coming back to
ultimate it's probably gonna be a pretty
smooth transition I like yeah and they
even plan as I said before the pro
controller just feels so so nice but you
can still play the game there's the game
controls will be supported we have
new one we showed as well with the new
logo on there on the direct so there's a
chance to see that all happen as well so
awesome
we're looking at here oh now we're on
battlefield this is one of the classic
States people know most I got Samus
Bayonetta we got champion link this time
to again good old a little Maki so
you're saying he's got the remote bombs
he does have a room bomb so if we get
link to throw some bombs out powered by
the chicest slate kind of technology oh
hey
link was trying to throw bomb but then
he got launched oh wow that's part of
the fun to just the crazy everything
happening on the screen so my dream my
dream character for that I was hoping to
be announced not that there are enough
characters to talk about but would have
been like Ravalli one of the champions I
know I'm oh wow it's almost like in our
office just like obviously him shouting
Rivoli's gals now ready it's just I'm a
huge Ravalli fan from breadth of the
wild but I think it's okay with 64 other
characters to choose from anyway yes it
speaker Mac Bayonetta being here not
like as additional DLC after that we at
least yeah yeah so yeah and the roster
could be huge we decided to see how
that's gonna go all those different
stages the support of our biggest
crossovers of all time like that some
people kind of like a fanservice but I
mean it's getting its own game and just
for everyone who enjoys it's just nice
to share these characters together all
at once
and so is there any news on time frame
that you can tell people right now yeah
December 7th awesome I can't connect
December 7th the amiibo as well I didn't
mention the amiibo Ridley amiibo go make
it look we don't be a ridley me but we
already of inkling and there will be a
Daisy amiibo as well
awesome what do they unlock do they
unlock stuff in the game or is it just
the only Michonne so far is it someone
we did in the previous one with the Wii
U version first version is that FP yeah
actually train up your fighter to kind
of that FP character to kind of train
with that one as well and see where you
go so yeah
December 7th 64 characters so far are so
far down so far at least 64 more than 60
Daniel from antenna treehouse thank you
so much much for having me guys yeah
absolutely it's always fun to have any
think we were playing poking last year
yes and splatoon soon yeah you're a
frequent game spotter yeah remember yes
it's always fun to have you and thanks
so much for showing us Smash Bros live
especially we really appreciate it
actually
the Nintendo right behind right to go
play as well yeah again tomorrow morning
I think Jojo helped you get in yeah I'm
looking forward to that but anyway
Daniel thank you so much and if you're
watching from home that was smash bros
ultimate a live demo that'll be out
December 7th for Nintendo switch I'm
sure you can go see more of it on
GameSpot itself and also we will be back
shortly for Forza horizon for interview
right after this so stick around
[Music]